My name is はじめしゃちょー
I am the biggest うぉぇーー
I wanna talk English! wow
おぅぇー
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
今日はですね、ちょっとね、
とある実験的なことをしようと思います
皆様、iPhone使ってますでしょうか？
真ん中のHOMEボタンを長押しすると、Siriが起動します
え、英語か
とりあえず、今回の実験で必要なのは、Siriを英語の設定にすることです
設定の「一般」から、Siriの設定で普通に英語にできると思います。
今回ちょっと情報を頂いたんですけども、
Siriの設定を英語にして「Girl」
女の子って意味ですね
「Girl」と発音してみてください。
僕もなんか詳しいことはわからないんですけども
英語の設定にして、「Girl」ってSiriに言って
Siriが「girl」って認識してくれたら
なんか、すごいみたいです
何がすごいか分かんないんですけども、
なかなかちょっと、
なんだろ
やっぱ発音が、発音が難しいんだよね「Girl」って
僕も留学でちょっと英語を勉強したんですけども
正直「Girl」は難しいです
「R」と「L」の発音がね、違う
R
これが「R」です
「L」は
L
なんか、こう
舌を
レ、レ
R
これが「R」
これが「L」
L
ごめん...
俺もよく分かんないんだ
ごめんなさい
留学行ってたけど
正直よくわかんない
とりあえず、難しいことは事実です
留学してた外国の友達の中には、（ガールを）ギャールって言ってた奴もいました
ギャルじゃねえかみたいな
「Girl」の発音がすごい難しいので
それがなんか関係してんのかな？とか
勝手に思っています
Ladies & Gentlemen
っていうわけで今回実際に
このイギリス帰りの留学紳士
はじめしゃちょーが
Siriの「Girl」の発音を完全に認知します
今回はそれでこそ
僕の英語の発音のすばらしさを皆さんに見せつけられればいいなと思っております
ではいこう！
♪～
そうだよね
Galじゃ分かんないよね
yeah!
yeahなんて誰も言ってねえよ
ちょっとまって
これ難しいぞ
...はい
もう一回いきまししょう
魚だね
Yeah！
違うよ！
ありがとうございます
魚だって！
ちょっとまって
これ本当に難しいよ
馬鹿にしてるでしょGotchaじゃねえわ
Girl
お！お！
えっ？
「Girl」だよね？
いやいやでも
今の発音で合ってたんですか？
結構ふざけましたよ
通ったけど
今のが正しい発音？
今通じてました
いまのでいいの？
いやいやおかしいでしょ今の発音は
ちょっとちょっと今のは信憑性がないので
もう一回やってみましょう
Ｙou areってなっちゃったよ
be動詞の基本形だわ
え？これで通るのか
やっぱちょっとふざけた位がいいですね英語は
googleじゃねえわw
おー！
「Ｒ」はこもるんですよ口が
Ｒ
この動きが大事です
よくわかんないけどな！
でも通るっちゃ通るぞ
一応発音はなんかできてるみたいです
今google hotって出たっしょw
いやバカヤローw
Good morningなんて誰も言ってねえわw
いやこれ本当に
難しいですよ
滑舌が悪いからそもそも日本語も英語もわからない
まって俺これさ、
英語の発音の練習になるよ
「girl」の発音がちゃんとできてるってわかるから
俺すっごいなんかいい事してんじゃん今日
「Ｒ」と「Ｌ」の発音がちゃんとできるようになる
Will you marry me?
NO.
♪～